red state's heading back over biden's
border crisis florida is now suing to
stop catch and release
that comes amid another massive group of
migrants some 20 000 strong is getting
ready to head to the u.s and while the
white house says the border is closed
the migrants are saying otherwise i
would like a certain message for braden
because
a
haiti
more difficult will you go back to haiti
no no no no never never no never
so so many ironic things that are going
on in our country right now you know we
we say
that we want people to come into the
country because of humanity because
these people come from really rough
places around the world i've traveled
around we all have we've seen it and we
empathize with where they are but the
way this is set up at the border right
now is anything other than humane i mean
you're luring them across the border
thinking they can just come on in which
they can but what happens in the
meantime child trafficking fentanyl
coming in by the bail as we would say in
the country right now
you know women being raped and assaulted
as they come across and they're willing
to give all that up and put themselves
in that kind of danger to have a shot at
america but we're not handling it
correctly so we see this this carnage
continuing to go on and it's
heartbreaking dan how do you view what's
going on though you know you brought up
the word irony and the tragedies became
fentanyl again women being sexually
abused kids being trafficked and i
thought one of the most tragic ironies
of all was the day they closed the legal
border in del rio the port of entry and
the bridge
two legal people come here legally to
work across the border truckers that was
closed because 20 000 people decided to
enter illegally who ironically got in
before the legal truckers got it they
didn't open up the checkpoint two weeks
later think about for a second everyone
at home like processes horse blinders
for a minute right people walked up to
our fictitious there's no southern
border please let's stop the nonsense
you walked up illegally you got in the
country quicker than a trucker who works
for a living with that pass that global
entry pass he had to wait two weeks or
drive to a port entry 90 miles down the
road not if you hear illegally the most
tragic irony of all you're penalized
you're penalized for doing it correctly
why would you do it correctly i'm an
idiot just walk in illegally what's the
point friends of mine who are immigrants
to this country built businesses here
friends of mine around the united states
nobody hates illegal immigration more
than legal migrants they hate it more
than anybody dana do you have any
stories of folks that you know well
peter is a good example but not a great
example here's an example look he came
here he did it legally it took years and
um you know he's an educated person we
have resources we had all we had
internet access we could go through i
could call up the congressman and they'd
take my call
and
that's how you know we were able to do
the system and i remember saying to
peter at one point you can imagine why
people do this illegally because we're
educated people and it's
completely difficult for us to figure
out so the legal immigration system is
needs attention desperately and all of
this illegal activity is making
increases in legal immigration much much
harder the i also believe that there's
something we need to
remember
the criticism from the left about
obama as deporter in chief and now biden
as somebody they think it's horrendous
that he sent some of the young people
the single men back to haiti they think
that that is like human rights violation
so where we have uh
a thought of like we should have a legal
order like i think we need to understand
that they're being pulled in a
completely different direction
and one of the things is president biden
when he campaigned he was the moderate
guy
turned to normal everything's going to
be everything's really calm but if you
look at some of the policies that he's
put forward and then the legislative
initiatives he has moved left
so
watch this space pretty closely well
jesse american citizenship
the rights to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
these are things that that you earn
these are things that our forefathers
have earned all the men and women that
have died to keep those rights alive
does the world want those things yes
they do because they don't have those
things the right to pursue happiness
they don't have the right to do anything
that's why they want to come here but it
is unfair to the people that do it
correctly how do we explain this to
migrants that come over here and and go
through the paperwork like dana said
well no one pursues happiness more than
you john rick that's a fact so you are
uh you are a beacon shining that light
to the world pursuer that is true um i
did find it ironic you brought up irony
that
the illegal immigrant was wearing a
biden harris t-shirt i haven't seen an
american this year wear by tara's
t-shirt it's the first time i have it
says something on top of the box you
can't repeat you can't say it on
television right
here's why the biden game is so stupid
they went out last week the stiff at dhs
and says the borders closed then they go
on fox news sunday with wallace and they
said oh yeah you know all those haitians
they were
down at that tent city we let 12 000 of
them in
right we flew 4 000 back to haiti they
bit our agents on the flight but we let
12 000 in so i'm not great at math
that's why i'm here on fox but if you
that's what
two-thirds of the border is open
according to those statistics and that's
why people keep coming and now there's
another caravan 16 000 strong forming in
panama coming up through colombia and
guatemala and new mexico no one's
stopping these caravans wasn't harris
supposed to go down there and get to the
bottom of the root causes whatever
happened to mr diplomat joe biden he
hasn't stopped the damn thing and now
all these people here they're supposed
to report to a court date they're not
going to report they're going to flee
and he's not going to deport him you can
now commit assault you can as an illegal
haitian hit jesse waters in the head
with a baseball bat and
joe biden won't deport you under his own
rules we'll probably give that guy a
congressional medal of honor jessica
what listen you don't like seeing what
you're seeing either nobody can look at
del rio texas under the bridge and go
wow that's great i mean nobody likes
that i don't care what your politics are
that is inhumane
the position that they're in so why do
we not close the border
well they they have moved very quickly
to get those thirty thousand people that
were under the bridge i mean that took
what two days in the end once it started
getting it just get them all in well
they haven't let people in jessica
i understand that and i just wanted to
say that president obama finally weighed
in on this he hadn't said anything for a
long time j j johnson who was a dhs
secretary had talked about it and he
finally said it's time to do something
and he brought back up comprehensive
immigration reform which both sides
always pay lip service too but i'm
wondering if him weighing in will tilt
the balance a little bit to jesse's
point i actually carry a biden harris
bag you see it every day and you sit
next to me for an hour i've noticed just
come downtown and you'll see biden swag
everywhere i don't go downtown come down
to florida they don't like me you see a
lot of biden swag but again it has a
wrong word in front by